québec donne une poussette plus à
l'avion a320 d'airbus autrefois la
cseries il va s'investir à mirabel un
milliard deux cents millions us donc
c'est tout une annonce la province
injectera 300 millions de dollars
américains dans la société en commandite
airbus canada le transporteur pour sa
part insuffle 900 millions de dollars et
québec s'est assuré d'obtenir une
garantie du maintien des 2500 emplois
actuels à l'usiné de mirabel
si jamais pire scénario il ya aucun
emploi créé pendant les six prochaines
années à mirabel le gouvernement du
québec doit pouvoir exiger que
l'accompagnement airbus rachète le
placement à 300 millions us françois
nebout voulait ainsi éviter le même
scénario qu'avec la cseries alors que le
gouvernement de philippe couillard avait
injecté 1 milliard de dollars américains
en 2015 un investissement qui ne vaut
plus un sens aujourd'hui depuis la vente
de l'appareil de bombardier à airbus si
on n'avait pas réussi
la part du gouvernement dans la 220 a
été pratiquement éliminés le potentiel
de faire l'argent est là pour cet expert
il n'y a pas de doute québec a fait le
bon choix plus on investit plus on
accélère la production plus on va les
chercher
c'est comment la bourse devenir des
l'argent qui entre la 220 est devenu
l'avion soussou dans sa catégorie et le
carnet de commandes est plein 500
appareils devaient être assemblés puis
livrée dans les prochaines années à des
entreprises comme air canada air france
et egyptair la 220 est aujourd'hui
l'avion dans sa catégorie qui est le
plus économe en carburant et donc en
émission donc un grand c'est un atout et
les compagnies aériennes nos clients le
voit
à mirabel où sont assemblés la plupart
de ses avions la nouvelle est bien reçu
c'est bien pour des emplois et puis
c'est bien pour le futur ça garantit les
emplois et avec cette annonce le airbus
annoncent qu'ils vont avoir une relation
à long terme avec le québec avec
airbus canada soit créé au moins 500
nouveaux emplois avec cet investissement
et augmenter sa cadence de production
l'entreprise assemble en ce moment
quatre appareils par mois il vote en
assemblée une quinzaine mensuellement
d'ici 2025 ici jérôme bergeron radio
canada montréal